it's great to be joined today by
Summerlee who is a Democratic Socialist
running to become state representative
from the 34th District of Pennsylvania
if she wins she would be the first
african-american woman elected to the
state legislature from southwestern
Pennsylvania so summer I mean let's
start with the most obvious right
Democratic Socialist how did you end up
in life as a Democratic Socialist yeah
that's a really good question it kind of
just happened I guess I think perhaps
intuitively you know I don't really
think vote for my community
you know just growing up you know poor
black community you know capitalism
doesn't really work for us so when I
actually didn't know about the GSA II
before I decided to run but when I did
the siren I kind of started looking into
them I was like well you know what this
the principle is aligned and in perhaps
when we didn't have like the language to
kind of describe the way we believe the
economics should work and socio-economic
should work but I think intuitively I
probably always happen so talk a little
bit about the values that you ascribe to
democratic socialism because there is
some confusion that stemmed I think in
great part from Bernie Sanders candidacy
in 2016
confusion between democratic socialism
and social democracy right more in line
with the sort of more heavily regulated
capitalism of Scandinavian countries
that includes a strong social safety net
so you are to be very very clear you're
talking about socialism not social
democracy what elements attracted you to
socialism rather than the social
democracy model well you know what I
wouldn't I wouldn't say that I'm
necessarily I'm against a social
democracy model I don't actually know
that I've ever articulated either one of
those as as my principles because to be
completely honest I'm not really it I've
never really paid very much attention to
distinctions what I know is that when
our government when our state invests in
people instead of corporations will be
better off so policies that I think will
be prudent you know investing in
education investing in education you
know pre-k through college
there are countries
when you look at the Scandinavian
countries you know where they do have
free education there's a reason why you
know there is free education in these
states and I think when you go to a best
in your people and young people growing
up they'll be more equipped to kind of
you know be a part of the economy I
graduated with over $200,000 in loan
debt it's very hard to envision or even
to kind of a fuel any of the things that
I want to do because when you graduate
with such debt you know it's a burden it
keeps you from participating in society
the way you might want to so that's one
thing I believe that our government that
our country that we should be investing
in medical care for our people so you
know I think two basic things so when we
look at what we're investing in people
in people's health our education in
health I mean I think those are
common-sense policies and I think that
they are not without you know they're
not out of grass yeah I don't disagree
with you I guess my question is in what
you're saying sounds very similar to my
views and I am NOT a socialist but I am
in favor of social democracy I guess I'm
curious you know
okay so sorry so are you not actually a
democratic socialist actually never
responded to any of them I have been
label you know socialists in a lot of
the publications but I've never said you
know I'm a socialist I'm a Democratic
Socialist I've just allowed it to go on
so to be clear you're not in favor for
example of total shared ownership of
businesses the way that socialism might
be in favor of it sounds like you're
actually more in favor of social
democracy absolutely oh okay okay let's
talk about some of the issues I mean
what your district is an interesting
district in that it has number one like
some other districts more markedly than
others a significantly lower median
income for African American folks than
for white folks that's an issue that
relates directly to business climate and
industry and employment can you talk a
little bit about economically what your
priorities would be so when you look at
some of the towns in our district in my
district that or blacker that are all
you know noticeably poor what we have is
kind of infrastructure failure we have a
lack of education and we have a lack of
jobs in these to me like in the
communities proper I'm so I grew up in
Braddock which is a community that used
to be a steel town it was a big steel
town and everybody that was the industry
and at one point in time everybody
worked you know or everyone knew someone
who worked in the steel mill I have some
indications to 70s and now at this point
you know we had this you know fracking
proposal which is basically saying our
talent is so desperate for jobs and for
some sort of economic revitalization
that we will kind of take anything or
that they think that they can propose
anything to us what I would say is is
that one of the things we need to do and
we're looking at economic revitalization
in some of these town but these black or
poor towns which would make up the Mon
Valley portion of my district we need to
look at you know investing public
dollars into our infrastructure into our
roads into building affordable housing
that would create jobs within our
community that can be filled within our
community but it would also create a
living space that is desirable that
would keep the folk who are already in
our community that will prime our
community for businesses if we want to
talk about businesses and you know
people coming in and creating businesses
in our building in our communities but
we need we need real estate for that we
need a thriving kind of business
district that has property that's well
you know well cared for that people
could be ready to move into immediately
and we don't necessarily have that here
so I mean it's a lot that needs to go on
economically you know to create
businesses and to create and generate
jobs that I think investing public
dollars into that would be I think you
know just maybe a common sensical way of
kind of up starting that so I'm going to
ask this next question as neutrally as
possible because I just want to hear
your thoughts on it
how where does the money for that come
from does it come from deficit spending
does it come from reallocating money
that's already being collected by state
and federal government does it come from
new taxes or tax increases and if so on
who yeah I would say a combination so we
look at reallocating money that we
already
Abin state I mean we have it's not that
the state doesn't have money is that the
state invest word invest and obviously
that's the legislature you know where we
prioritize is you know our governor or
legislature you know we've had tax we
have we've had spending cuts to
education but we've had increased
spending in you know prisons and you
know building prisons and maintaining
our prisons and increasing our prison
population so that's one thing right now
we have one of the fifth most regressive
tax systems in a country in Pennsylvania
so we have you know the flat tax rate so
our millionaires are emotionally paying
you know less than our working class
people so we're talking abut just to be
clear summer you're talking about state
income tax right yeah okay so a
millionaire's tax and is something that
we'd have to go through the
constitutional we need a constitutional
amendment to do that but that's money
that we have and another revenue source
that I would not and I want to be very
clear with this I wouldn't advocate for
this primarily I would advocate for a
moratorium on fracking but the fact that
we don't have a severance tax on oil and
gas is it's just baffling you know they
come into our communities they can
extract you know minerals it can
distract you know something from from
the Commonwealth and they don't have to
pay taxes on it which means that they
don't have to contribute to our schools
per se you know we had these property
taxes to fund our schools but they don't
have to contribute to that you know
they're not fixing our roads when you
know their trucks are riding up and down
them and destroying them so that is
baffling to me so there are definitely
you know sources of revenue that we can
tap in for these things when it comes to
like a millionaire's tax or maybe like a
progressive state income tax you know
most states have a flat income taxes as
you point out what specifically would
that look like in other words would you
create a new bracket and if so what
would the rate be and at what income
level would it kick in or how would you
structure that yeah that's a good
question that I don't actually
necessarily have the answer for at this
moment having not you know dealt in
taxes but looking at you know kind of
what we have right now and realizing
that
you know this is not the tax structure
that week that is maybe best for our
state I think that there are a lot of
smart cloak in our legislature right now
who really need to come together and
start thinking about you know why are we
giving you know tax breaks to
corporations - to our millionaires why
are a millionaire spending more money
and I think oftentimes we kind of talk
about these tax you know we do tax
increases we talk about how that's going
to affect our middle class and our in
our lower middle class but we never talk
about the fact that we actually could
just tax are millionaires more they
should be paying proportionately higher
and that they can pay that so then yeah
I don't disagree with you I guess I
think sometimes where candidates will go
a bit not astray but where they can get
muddled up on that issue is not having a
strong sense of who pays it and how much
right and I think that there might be my
view is there might be more willingness
to say I that's something I can get
behind if they heard a specific proposal
and they know okay I don't have to
imagine how bad it might be here's what
it is and I think that makes sense or it
doesn't make sense but at least we're
talking about a specific proposal you
know oh yeah by the time I get to the
legislature you know des December oh
they'll definitely have a specific
proposal right now will they be more you
know what will that make them feel
better probably not just getting you
looking at our legislature out so
clearly on economics and climate change
are both important issues to you when
you mention fracking you talked about
both the environmental and the economic
what are the other most important issues
in the Pennsylvania 34th district I
would say education is definitely I
think that because you know these issues
are cyclical so even as we campaign we
were not able to necessarily divorce
all of these issues from each other so
education does tie into jobs the science
economics does tie into our environment
because what you see specifically in a
34th you know we have these you know
polluters we have incredible air
pollution that is you know worse in the
nation then we have the fracking
proposal but you'll notice that those
you know polluters are usually put into
communities that are poor that are more
vulnerable those communities are also
more likely to have you know less
for their education so education funding
is huge that's actually how I got into
this you know we had I went to a public
school our public school right now is
it's really being devastated by a few
things one of them our charters you know
this increased presence of charters in
our district because our district is it
is failing there are a lot of issues
that come along with not having an
equitable funding scheme and our zip
code definitely is to detriment of our
students but we definitely need to
restore funding the education and not
think that your zip code should not
determine how good your education is
minimum wage I think is a thing that is
as big you know in Pennsylvania we are
still at 7:25 mmm so every state around
us has increased their minimum wage but
us so in our district and in the parts
of our district in district 30 for that
are poor they are more likely to have
you know less money for the education
system fewer jobs in the area but bust
cuts into your bus routes and a very
expensive you know bus system like
Pittsburgh Port Authority is very
expensive so it's very hard for folk in
those areas to get out to get to those
job centers so that's a big one and I
will say Medicare is something else that
resonated everywhere we went in our
district when we talked about you know a
single-payer medical system medical care
system that resonated with folk and
especially in conjunction when we're
talking about the environmental issues
that we have hmm so when your Democratic
primary you were up against and defeated
Paul Costa whose family is I mean it's a
political dynasty family I'm curious
whether you think that those family
political dynasties are sort of
inherently bad for democracy I think it
can be unchecked I mean I would never
say that just because you come from a
particular family that you can't you
know pursue your dreams if you're
talented you know you should be able to
do it now I will say that we have to
check that you know when you have a
situation where everybody on your family
is in politics which means that you're
probably more likely to have money
probably more likely to have you know an
extensive network that will protect you
that will circle the wagons when you're
threatened and but also your your your
record doesn't up you know you
record isn't you know where it should be
you know it shouldn't be good enough in
our country that you can lean on your
name or you can lean on your money you
can lean on your family that's a problem
now that is a problem you know I went up
against a 19 year incumbent his brother
was is the minority leader of the Senate
you know so there's power there and
there were a lot of folk who in our
district believed that perhaps we should
have more more progressive
representative that we could have a more
progressive representative believe that
you know maybe his policies didn't
necessarily align or maybe his vision
for our district didn't necessarily
align with the district itself but
because his brother is who he is because
his cousin is who he is because his
friends in politics are who they are
they were worried about going up against
them so that definitely creates a
barrier for you know regular folk from
folk from different backgrounds to enter
into this view so yeah that's definitely
problematic
summerlee is in a very very interesting
race in the Pennsylvania 34th district
we are going to link in the description
for the YouTube clip for this story to
her website you can learn more about the
campaign and summer thank you so much
for talking to me and best of luck in
the campaign thank you